[Music]
for two weeks now the prime time team's
been fighting a war on Christmas
happening in the Tiny Town of Dedham
Massachusetts it started when a
Persnickety librarian banned Christmas
trees in the libraries because they made
people feel uncomfortable
and the good news is prime time
intervened and now the trees are back
but that's not the end of the story you
see the Christmas loving people of dead
in Massachusetts aren't very happy with
what unfolded many say it's been an
attack on Christianity and last night
they crowded into the town hall and
spoke directly to the library board
watch
associated with it to others as a
taxpaying member of this community we
should all be represented not just
why do you hate Christians so much this
is not about a Christmas tree this is
about you trying to lead the town into
being woke
these people now are watching you
I'm not here tonight to defend anything
but one thing I am here to to do tonight
is to say that the Christmas tree
should have been up I'm Jewish for me
Christmas is
sorry Christmas is a time of peace
it's a time we should give respect to
everybody I'm
sad having been a life resident of this
town that the board didn't say anything
except that they were still decorating
and working on on
a conversation that happened back in the
spring
there's been a tree in this town for 30
years
at the library and all of a sudden it's
not there this year so it was disturbing
you decided not to have a tree for
whatever biases that you may have you
thought nobody was going to find out
about it thankfully Mrs Desmond said
something thankfully Turtle Boy picked
up the story thankfully Jesse Waters
picked up the story the local media
everybody picked up the story and now
you're just sitting in the pile of poop
that you made for yourself if I tell you
right now if I had little kids I would
move away because of all you people none
of you had to
the courage to stand up and do what was
right you embarrassed us all over a tree
our fearless foot soldier Lisa Desmond
was also at the meeting and tried to
keep the peace but at the end of the day
all these people one is for the holidays
to be celebrated hopefully the town
learns from this and perhaps next year
they can speed up the decoration review
process so that the trees can go up
before Christmas day as they do
everywhere else